My final and perhaps most important piece of advice is to respect your audience.
Use color scales that everyone can see.
If you're looking at the circle on the screen, then you've likely noticed
the number 74 disguised as green dots among the many red dots.
If you can't see the 74, then you may be part of the approximately 10% of males
and 1% of females who suffer from a color deficiency known as colorblindness.
Red and green colorblindness is the most prevalent, but
there are other types too.
Check out the Wikipedia article in the instructor notes to learn more
of the details.
We've also included some colorblindness tests in the instructor notes and
a link to some recommended color palates.